Is kissing really a universal sign of romantic
love, and sexual attraction?
Or could you be sending the wrong signals?
Hello everyone, Crystal here for DNews working
on my relationship skills and looking for
evidence that a kiss on the lips really does
mean the same thing in every culture...
In his writings, F. Scott Fitzgerald famously
said: “The kiss originated when the first
male reptile licked the first female reptile,
implying in a subtle, complimentary way that
she was as succulent as the small reptile
he had for dinner the night before.”
While weird and oddly sweet, this quote also
seems to imply that romantic kissing evolved
as humanity did, but science says that may
not actually be true.
First of all what possible evolutionary benefit
would be gained by exposing ourselves to potential
pathogens and slobbering all over the person
we love?
...Honestly, kissing really should seem gross
but somehow ... really isn’t.
In my favorite fun to talk about but difficult
to reproduce, “sweaty T-shirt study”,
scientists demonstrated that women were attracted
to the smell of sweaty T-shirts belonging
to males that genetically expressed immune
related proteins that were complementary to
their own; indicating a link between genetic
complementarity and sexual attraction.
Given the intimate relationship that exists
between smell and taste it would not be surprising
to find that kissing is another way for us
to asses the genetic viability of our potential
mates.
Actually, science has proposed that kissing
may be a way of using additional senses to
help us determine everything from health,
to the genetic deviation and hormonal profiles
of our partners.
All of which are determining factors in sexual
attraction.
But what evidence is there that “kissing
may be a human universal rather than a culturally
variable display of affection?”
Scientists from the University of Nevada Las
Vegas, and Indiana University asked exactly
that question in a recent paper published
in the journal American Anthropologist.
In their study, the researchers asserted that
when it comes to kissing, intent matters.
They defined romantic-sexual kissing that
occurs between lovers as a sub-group of general
kissing behavior and then they examined the
prevalence of that intentionally erotic, focused,
lip to lip contact in cultures around the
world.
Using a combination of existing databases
and reports from individual ethnographers,
the authors surveyed 168 cultures from nine
geographical areas and they examined incidence
of romantic-sexual kissing in common social
practice.
The results indicate that the prevalence of
romantic-sexual kissing was not universal
at all.
In fact, within the majority of cultures (54%)
surveyed, romantic mouth to mouth kissing
was not the accepted social practice!
While this may seem surprising to us, (previous
reports have indicated that kissing was near
universal) the authors warn against western
ethnocentrism by stating “while kissing
may be a way to communicate intimacy in some
societies or may function as a specific eroticized
activity in others, it is important to note
that for quite a few kissing is seen as unpleasant,
unclean, or simply unusual.”
There are, as always, subtleties in the conclusions
of this study.
For instance, there is no mention of what
portion of the total earth’s population
is composed of cultures that do not accept
romantic kissing as common practice.
Interestingly, the authors do also report
a correlation between a culture’s level
of social complexity and the presence or absence
of the romantic–sexual kiss.
They found that cultures that scored high
on a scale of social complexity and had distinct
social classes were more likely to accept
the romantic-sexual kiss as a common practice,
and they speculate that the evolution of the
kiss may coincide with the development of
oral hygiene or social values of self-control
in public emotional displays.
Regardless, after reading their study, we
are left with the idea that while kissing
may not be a universal part of the human sexual
repertoire, the behavior is anchored in the
“truly universal human capacity for romantic
love.”
For more on what we think we know about the
science of kissing, check out this video by
Anthony
and Laci